hello and welcome to the take with me
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
hearts of Westminster now there was
plenty of the usual division to be seen
today not least the all-out war that
Boris Johnson is unleashing on well just
about everybody ahead of tomorrow's
verdict on whether he misled Parliament
but there was also unity and shared
compassion for the suffering of the
community in Nottingham reeling from
yesterday's attacks where three people
lost their lives two students and a
school caretaker now one of those
occasions on which as the cliche goes
the House of Commons is at its best so
there's plenty of us to talk about as we
bring you takes from all sides over the
next 60 minutes and we have some top
political guests on the program on a day
when the violence in Nottingham is
dominating the agenda including the home
office Minister Chris philp and also the
shadow policing Minister Sarah Jones
speaking for labor plus we're going to
be talking to Claire Hannah of the stlp
on the rise of domestic violence that's
and much more besides on Tech thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
good evening well we can crack straight
on shall we in a moment we will get the
latest from Nottingham but I just want
to kick off with our rundown of the
political weeks so far
good evening then from Nottingham a city
in shock tonight after a series of
violent attacks left three people dead
and others injured very moving vigil
full of people full of emotion and
family members the love that we have out
here are just
which we got it everywhere Rishi sinak
has hit back at Boris Johnson this
morning in a row over the former prime
minister's resignation on his list Boris
Johnson asked me to do something that I
wasn't prepared to do because I didn't
think it was right and if people don't
like that then tough no I wouldn't
describe the committee as a kangaroo
court not at all the Scottish national
party says it's not going to suspend its
former leader Nicholas sturgeon
following her arrests over the weekend
but individuals have been released
without charge let me emphasize that
without charge that therefore I see no
reason to suspend them interest rates
appear likely to increase even further
and for many they're already painfully
High I'm afraid this morning's numbers
Illustrated we've got a very tight labor
market in this country we've we've had a
fall in the supply of labor which is
showing signs of recovering but very
slowly frankly we will support the bank
of England to do what it takes to bring
down inflation and have a look where we
are right now is actually the highest
since 1991. all across the country
people are worried about their bills and
the spiraling mortgage rates
so why has the Tory party spent this
last week arguing over which of them
gets a peerage i predecessor may not
have agreed with Labor's choices of Tom
Watson or shami chakravarti
[Applause]
[Music]
aim precedent stood then as it does now
and I'd expect a night like him to
understand that
you're just watching that back Boris
Johnson quitting Parliament Nicholas
sturgeon getting arrested you just think
that at some point politics is going to
calm down but it never quite works out
that way but our first story tonight is
the thing that every party leader talked
about at Prime Minister's questions the
attacks in Nottingham that led to the
deaths of three people including two 19
year old students and a caretaker well
politicians across the house voice their
sympathy and their solidarity with the
city
Mr Speaker I know the whole house will
want to thank the emergency services for
their ongoing response to the shocking
incident in Nottingham yesterday our
thoughts are with those injured and with
the families of those who lost their
lives the thoughts of the whole house
are with the victims and the people of
that great City
it is absolutely heartbreaking to see
the pictures of University of Nottingham
students Barnaby and Grace whose young
lives so full of potential have been
tragically cut short this is an
extraordinarily difficult time and every
parent's worst nightmare at the hearts
of the whole country are with the
families and all those who have lost
their lives
at awful moments like this Mr Speaker it
is vital that we come together as a
country
and I have no doubt that we will
the city of Nottingham and all its
people are at the Forefront of all our
minds
and every resource of the state is at
their disposal
we can bring in our crime correspondent
Martin brunt he joins us now from
Nottingham I mean Martin the image that
I just can't get out my head is the two
fathers
standings side by side incredibly
dignified talking about what happened
and what's the latest
in a truly extraordinary day
um
you know that massive vigil at the
University of Nottingham and amid the
pain and the anguish some extraordinary
uplifting moments particularly in the
tributes to those three uh victims um
incredibly moving words from the fathers
of the two students who stood side by
side talking uh about their murdered
children I mean how can they possibly
have imagined
48 hours ago that they would be standing
together talking like that and bonded
together by this extraordinary tragedy I
mean I don't even know if those two men
had ever met one another before but also
of course A continuing police
investigation
um the crime scenes here have been
dismantled so the investigation as it
goes on from now is largely unseen
behind closed doors there's the
continuing interview of the suspect the
31 year old man who was arrested in the
early hours of yesterday morning but
there's also the examination
of CCTV footage uh all sorts of other
security camera footage that would have
been seized and also if they have them
the
electronic devices of the suspect
perhaps his mobile phone uh his laptop
any other computers that he may have
used all of that is continuing we don't
know yet whether the police have got an
answer to what happened it's looking
more and more less likely that this was
a terror attack or a series of Terror
attacks still very much a crime
investigation if police have already
discovered what lies behind it we don't
know yet they haven't told us but they
have until Saturday morning to hold
their suspect continue questioning and
at that stage they'll have to decide
whether to charge him or releasing
Martin thank you very much indeed Martin
brunt there in Nottingham a city
still reading from what happened well
you may have seen the crime and policing
Minister Chris philp who was alongside
the Home Secretary in the House of
Commons today I caught up with him a
little earlier
I was just hoping to get some
Reflections from you first on the
absolutely pulling tragedy that we've
seen in knotting I'm sure you've been as
moved as everyone
well first of all I mean our hearts go
out to the families of the victims two
young people cut down in the prime of
Life their Futures ahead of them so for
their families I mean speaking as a
parent as well I just can't imagine the
pain and the anguish they must be
feeling tonight and of course um the
other victim a man who'd served his
local community as a school caretaker
um tragically murdered as well so I
think first and foremost our thoughts
should be with those families
um I think we should also pay tribute to
the emergency services who responded so
quickly on the scene almost immediately
and made an arrest within a couple of
hours so and we should just thank and
pay tribute to those
um brave men and women who serve in
uniform to keep the rest of us or to
protect the public and and to catch um
criminals for responding so quickly and
for apprehending uh what appears to be
the perpetrator so quickly as well do
you have any concerns at all about the
response to the emergency services or
perhaps monitoring this individual
previously well I think the emergency
service response was was incredibly fast
they were as I said on the scene almost
to me immediately they made an arrest
within a couple of hours local policing
have been supported immediately by
counterterrorism policing as well
although no finding has been made at
this point of any terrorist connection
so the whole system responded I think
really quickly we can be I think proud
of the response to that emergency
services
um put on so no concerns about that but
none of that of course in any way just
mitigates the awful tragedy that's
happened and the anguish of the families
and friends of the victims must be
feeling this evening it's been
incredibly moving day looking at some of
those scenes coming from Nottingham as
you say so many communities impacted by
what happened
um another subject that I was Keen to
talk about today is mortgages because
frankly I think that it is something
that is preying on an awful lot of
people's minds at the minute perhaps
something that you know we in the media
and politicians and Westminster haven't
really focused on enough you might say
too
I mean people are going to be spending
thousands of pounds more on their
mortgages are you worried
look I think it is a concern because
people pay money each month to to
service their mortgage I mean some
people are on fixed rates so they won't
be affected yet but other people are on
variable rate mortgages or their fixed
rate may be coming to an end so it is a
concern because it's money you have to
pay every single month month in month
out I think in common with the rest of
Europe
uh interest rates and and America for
that matter the USA you know interest
rates
um are higher than we would like it's
not just the UK it's Europe and it's
it's America as well all of this of
course links back to inflation the
reason
um the bank of England
um the the Federal Reserve in America
and the European Central Bank have all
put up interest rates over the last year
and a half or so is to combat inflation
that's why I think it's right that Rishi
sunaka said one of his top priorities
this year is that it's the half
inflation because if inflation comes
down then interest rates can come down
I'm done great job on it so far they
have it's pretty sticky inflation much
stickier than you perhaps thought so I
mean it is coming down which is a good
thing and the peak was a few months ago
it has come down since then uh inflation
here is is similar to inflation CPI
inflation uh across the European Union
8.7 and 8.1 percent but we'd like to get
it down a lot lower that partly requires
the bank of England to take action which
they're doing independently it means
we've got to be like financially
responsible with the government's money
so Labor's plan to splurge 28 billion
pounds although they have has to be fair
to labor they have changed that so they
were not going to do it immediately
they're going to do it when the economy
well they're still going to do it well
they and I think an independent uh body
has said that it will be inflationary
and I think Ed miliband is still
insistent they're going to do it
straight away so Labor's policies
well they've been a band appears to say
something else so they need to get their
act together and an independent body has
said it'll be inflationary I think the
other point is about creating more
capacity in the economy right because
the more there are people and businesses
producing goods and services if you've
increased Supply then prices will tend
to come down so the fact we have record
numbers of people in employment is
helpful that means more people are
producing producing things the economy
more widely despite the challenges of
Ukraine and everything else is growing
unlike
um the the Eurozone which is it well so
last year it was record growth in the G7
the year before that was record both in
the G7 I know but it's growing it's
growing slowly this year
but let's be clear Germany is in
recession the Eurozone is in recession
the IMF has just upgraded our growth
forecast by more than any other country
so I'm sure we were sitting here a few
months ago and you were you were quoting
the IMF forecast at me saying the
Eurozone is going to grow and we're
going to be in recession the truth that
was on your forecast the truth has
turned out to be exactly the opposite is
Germany in the Eurozone they're in
recession and the UK is growing we'd
like to grow faster of course but we are
at least growing and unemployment today
it's funny you're quoting the IMF to me
because you're the one who was
rubbishing the island a couple of times
previously when you've actually said you
know you don't believe in a two-personal
and now you love them so make your mind
up no I'm I'm saying therefore it sounds
a bit like you're picking not at all I'm
saying no no the reverse I'm saying
they're forecast I said here three
months ago their forecast would be wrong
and their forecast has turned out to be
wrong you know the word the thing that I
find a little bit strange is that you
know if everything is going so well
we've got growth we're doing much better
you know
um actually we've got this great plan
and people will be looking at their
mortgage bills and thinking why am I
feeling so broke why am I so worried no
no I cannot pay these
I'm not saying everything is perfect of
course I'm not I'm saying they're a
really serious prop challenges Across
the Western World and here in Europe and
the US with inflation being higher than
we wanted to be with interest rates
being higher
with these serious challenges Across the
Western World I guess you could forgive
voters from looking at the conservative
uh politicians who are currently in
government thinking I do not trust these
people to get us out of this hole well
look it's just look at the the numbers
right we've got uh growth we are growing
unlike the Germans and the Eurozone
which is in recession
um we've got
um unemployment is half the level now as
a percentage compared to the last Labor
government so there's a lot of progress
being made but there's a lot more to do
clearly I think Rishi sunak is focusing
on the right things right halving
inflation growing the economy reducing
debt those are all the right things to
focus on he's making he's making steady
methodical process let's progress and
that is what the public expects let's
look at some of the study methodical
progress under which you've seen it
shall we I think we can have a look at
mortgage repayments uh currently this is
what people are expected to be repaying
on their mortgages going back over time
should be with us very soon here we go
you can say you can see there that the
projected costs of people's mortgage
repayments is going to be up to the
highest since
1991. it's worth pointing out as well
that people borrowed more now right so
this is going to be more painful so this
is the mortgage repayments you can see
the steady progress of Russia CNAC there
and also can look at the yields as well
this is effectively UK borrowing costs
so what the money markets that it is on
the government if you like
the dotted line there is the mini budget
of Liz truss and you can see that UK
borrowing course yields are now back up
to the same
about is that many budgets so what you
should do next time is add a second line
onto that chart which is the U.S
treasury yields and apart from the spike
around the mini budget which you can see
went up and then went down you'll see
the US numbers similar to ours so I'm
just I'm just looking at the UK here
I'm just I'm just saying that people
just like this I'm just feeling like I
was making the point that you're saying
this is you know blaming the government
I'm just pointing out respectfully that
this is happening Across the Western
World the the US figure for two-year
guilds is 4.6 ours is 4.8 they're
basically the same now that's the first
point the second point is yes we need to
take action we do the US government does
the Europeans do it so what can we do so
so the reason that that um yields are
going up like like your short shows is
that interest rates Central Bank base
rates are going up right Central Bank
base rates are going up because
inflation is high now some of the causes
of inflation are external like the war
in Ukraine but there are things we can
do
um domestically one of those is being
responsible with public finances because
being irresponsible tends to drive
inflation
it's not the only Factor but it's one of
them so I think being
um responsible on uh wage increases
including in the public sector is one of
the things we need to do
um stepping in to people are you
considering that I I just I'm really
interesting what do you mean stepping in
to help people who might be looking at
their mortgage bills and not be able to
pay it subsidizing people's mortgage
payments so Health out on the table so
helping with the cost of living I mean
it's something the government's been
doing for the last year a specifically
the average mortgage to be clear I mean
to be clear people who rent as well are
facing pressure unless it's not just
mortgage holders um so the average
household has received three thousand
pounds in government assistance over the
last year is it on the table or not
we're helping everybody right whether
they've got a mortgage or whether
they're renting so that doesn't look
like specific action well we're helping
everybody and we're helping everybody
and that help adds up to 3 000 pounds a
year which I think is a really
significant intervention now there's a
couple of other things I do want to ask
you about uh Boris Johnson resigned as
an MP after the Privileges committee uh
report into partygate but he misled
parliament are you sorry to see them go
well I mean he made his decision to
resign and because he thought that the
committee was going to find against him
that was like his decision I think I
have slightly mixed feelings to be
honest um I mean I think we should
recognize that he
um has some kind of impressive
accomplishments right I mean the vaccine
roll out was was World leading
um his support for Ukraine he was the
first uh major Western leader to go in
and support Ukraine before the Americans
were supplied more support more weapons
but Boris was first and he led the way
and that's why he's sort of fated and
and adored by by ukrainians um he's a
great political Communicator obviously
so those are all huge qualities but
obviously his you know conduct
um didn't meet the standard we expect in
public life which is why he went as
prime minister and then more recently
went as an MP and I think the public do
expect to see high standards in public
life I remember
um you know about a year ago when there
were party gate stuff was current
um just how angry
um people were about the way Boris had
conducted himself like visceral anger so
I think the public do expect people to
be held to account so you know I'm sad
that someone with those qualities and
that has made those achievements is
leaving but I think standards in public
life
um do need do need to be up held and are
are important so I've got those sort of
mixed emotions yeah
um saying that Bernard Jenkins a concert
of mp on the Privileges committee should
quit because he went to a party
do you feel that look Boris has got a
point that there's a Witch Hunt against
him or do you think that actually he's
starting to look a bit bitter
um but I certainly wouldn't wouldn't use
that word I think look there's a process
that has to be gone through and we
should go through the process and that
should apply and that should apply
um you know because the public do expect
to expect standards okay thank you very
much thank you
oh well later the prayer all that
Labor's at take on all that but that was
uh Chris felt there and we've got um
some coats stunning but I definitely put
together so to have a bit of a chat
through the interview as well you saw
him grappling a bit there I thought
didn't you it's interesting Chris Philip
always goes into these interviews like
ready for battle and then you saw that
with the jousting if you like on
mortgages but when it came to Boris
Johnson I think you got a bit more of a
sense of how he's really feeling a bit
mixed emotions I guess my question to
you Sam is tomorrow we're going to get
this long awaited report from the
Privileges committee I mean we already
know what's in there because he's
basically told us
but what will it mean is tomorrow going
to be the day that Boris Johnson is
buried or is he right for a comeback I
mean that's a great question because
that that's exactly what I'm looking for
because the 30 000 words and we will
read it uh and it'll be on Sky News from
9am tomorrow uh will be all about
whether or not this guy misled
Parliament when it came to what happened
during party games now because of the
leaks because we watch the testimony
because we've been here quite a long
time we we broadly know the answer that
he will be found uh to have breached uh
multiple breaches effectively uh of the
standards that MPS um should uphold it's
quite interesting listening to Chris
Phillips language he is out because he
doesn't uphold those standards that the
public expect of MPS of a prime minister
and chose to resign he says as well and
chose to resign but the question for me
is not what's in the report but how do
conservatives conservative MPS react
because there are those MPS who are
vocally supportive of Boris Johnson in
Parliament quite a lot less of them as
it happens because two of them resigned
uh Maddie Doris we will probably step
down a bit closer to the summer and uh
Nigel Adams uh there'll be a by-election
for him uh next month
um but the question is are there signs
that Boris Johnson still enjoys the
support and this is a matter of regret
for a large or even a small minority of
Tory MPS or is this the moment that
people go actually what's happening is
that a disgraced act MP who was slung
out of office uh as prime minister is
now leaving the public stage and really
as we look at mortgages as we look at
that Dreadful in Nottingham yet the news
agenda is still stuck on Boris Johnson
the question is after tomorrow does the
Tory party draw a line under it or do
they keep talking about the man who was
once King was once King there you go it
does feel like that doesn't it
particularly Rishi seen it perhaps
getting a bit empowered shall we say in
some of his criticisms of his previous
asset thanks very much for your analysis
Sam we'll have more from Sam later in
the program including his take on some
of those by-elections that are coming up
we are live here in Westminster for you
up next we'll be talking to you later
Sarah Jones about whether Labor's plan
for the economy Stacks up
[Music]
foreign
Thomas Peter and I'm Sky's climate
change correspondent
thank you
the UK is a world leader in wind power
people
it's part of the Congo Basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of Africa we aim
to be the best and most trusted place
for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me I might be just very
naive but I do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
for the last 30 years we have known how
bad it is I'm not here to apologize I'm
here to fight for the next step
you can see just just the bills and
piles of stuff these the sofas and
people's desks and children's books and
you can see inside this home here people
trying to to sort out their home it's
just been devastating
I think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of this beauty
around us
the future of you and me
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back live to Westminster you're
watching the take well we can hear from
labor now it's the day where Circus
Dharma took aim at the Prime Minister
for waving through Boris Johnson's
nominations for honors as well as the
government's economic record and he
ended up with a challenge to him to call
a general election well a little earlier
I spoke to the shadow policing Minister
Sarah Jones
I want to start with the appalling
tragedy in Nottingham I mean I like so
many people been really moved to see the
dignity with the victims parents have
spoken with today what are your
reflections
well we had a statement in Parliament
today with the Home Secretary talking
about the police response and it was one
of those times when it was Parliament at
its best because we were all United
there were tears there was
um shared
talk about the the people who've lost
their lives the community that is
Nottingham the strength of the uh
Community there and we just already feel
for the families of those affected
um and we're really grateful to the
emergency services for their response
and from the the people who were there
on the scene which you can't imagine
having to deal with uh what they found
and the police who are now investigating
and we just need to give the police the
time to thoroughly investigate and find
out what went wrong and what uh what
happened to create such a terrible
tragedy do you have any questions about
the police response I haven't seen any
criticism from anybody about the police
response these things are always very
difficult it was the early hours of the
morning and it was what appears to be
entirely random and unseen and unfortune
attack so I think the response has been
very good there will be time to reflect
on that afterwards and I know the police
will do that themselves when you have
such a serious incident but the dignity
as you say within which the city has
responded the local people have
responded it's politicians have
responded the families have responded I
think um gives heart that it's not a
community that will break but it's one
that will try and celebrate the lives
that have been lost and those good lives
that were lived and we won't let this
bring the city down it's a very vibrant
Lively City full of thousands of
students and local people and long may
that continue yeah absolutely I think
everyone would agree with that
definitely
um it's always hard to move on to other
subjects after such a difficult story is
what happened in Nottingham but I do
really want to talk to you about
mortgages because it feels like this is
something frankly that we haven't really
been covering enough if you look at
what's happening to the mortgage market
and what it's going to mean for the
people impacted how worried are you
well I'm really worried I was talking to
a constituent at the weekend who was
going door-to-door with with a leaflet
for his business a an I.T business and
he didn't have enough money to pay the
bills he was trying to do everything he
possibly could uh to increase the money
coming in and he said to me his mortgage
is is up in October and he's going to
have to renew it now 116 000 people are
in the same boat every month
um having to uh change their mortgage
and the amount that that we're seeing
the increases are huge
um levels we're looking at well I think
the resolution Foundation said that
people on average will be paying over
two thousand pounds a year extra on
their mortgages which is incredibly high
and impossible for some people to manage
so it has to be something that we care
about and do something about and I think
what we've seen this week with the
chaos and arguments in government
between between different members of the
conservative party is such a distraction
from those real problems you're
absolutely right to raise it so it's a
real problem you say it's something we
need to look at and sort out so what is
labor going to do are you willing to
look at stepping in to subsidize
people's mortgages what's the plan so
the first thing is that we will be bound
by our fiscal rules whatever we do
because we have to bring stability back
to the economy so stability in
government means not having four
chancellors in four months does it also
means spending 28 billion pounds a year
on the green Prosperity well it means
not criticizing the institutions that
are and not attacking the institutions
that are that are there to help someone
um well we've seen that with the whole
Liz truss um
prime minister yes I I I I I know I'm
jumping in a bit but I think this is a
really important Point here it's very
easy to criticize the chaos that's gone
before yeah looking forward what is
Labor's plan to help people with their
mortgages to stabilize the economy the
fiscal rules of not borrowing uh for
day-to-day spend as as the conservatives
did in the last week it's 28 billion a
year is that the 28 billion a year by
the middle of the parliament because
that is what's going to drive job
creation and that is what is going to
drive growth in the economy and that is
what is going to drive the green energy
that will bring down costs in the long
term so there are there are a whole raft
of interventions from uh the top to the
bottom that labor will want to do so on
home ownership for example we really
want to increase home ownership so we
have to help people to buy and that is
going to be a challenge in the current
environment but there are things that we
can do I just want to jump ahead and do
that because the only thing you've said
about what you're going to do to sort
out the mortgage crisis is to stabilize
the economy but what does that mean
you're basically just saying oh we'll
just be a bit better than the
conservatives that's not really a policy
is it I mean there are things you could
do to bring down you know inflation
suppressing wages is tax Rises some of
these are quite ugly some of these these
are things that you might not want us to
do or you can step in and say yeah we're
going to help subsidize people's
mortgages what's the plan so on taxes
we're going to have a fairer tax system
that will help grow the economy to put
more money into people's pockets so does
that means Fair attack system for
example we want to get rid of business
rates and increase some of the taxes on
those digital firms that are not paying
the business rates that your Shops and
and other buddies are paying in our
towns so that we can Revive Our Town
centers which inflation it's personal
taxation that changes inflation that is
something that will help grow the
economy the green Prosperity plan which
will bring in with the private sector
really Turbo Charge uh the growth in in
jobs insulate those 18 million homes we
want to have an industrial strategy the
government doesn't believe in an
industrial strategy it doesn't believe
in that level of uh cooperation with the
private sector we think we need to bring
all those Industries together to look at
how we can grow the economy because we
have to do that we have to bring in
stability and grow the economy to bring
inflation down now there are other
things in the much longer term if you
look at what's happened globally
of course there have been these big
shocks that have driven up prices uh the
the war in Ukraine and covid have both
been big Global events but our economy
was quite exposed because it wasn't
growing fast and because we hadn't built
up some of those uh industries of the
future that we need to do so there are
some long-term things that can make us
more resilient so when there are Global
shocks we're better prepared and better
able to cushion uh the blow for people
but the fundamental point is an
absolutely clear one mortgages are going
up very substantially and we will have
people who can't afford to pay them and
the government needs to stop arguing
amongst itself and come back to this and
focus on it and we're very happy to work
with the government on what those things
around wasn't really impacting people's
mortgages is it and and like I'm just
trying to I think
I know it's I know no Economist but you
know I'm just struggling to work out why
you know taxing internet Giants and a 28
billion pound green Prosperity plan is
going to include some borrowing why that
is going to bring down inflation and
stop interest right hand I just don't
it's not is that right we need a stable
economy that's what's Driven up a lot of
the problems that we've seen so we had
the global situation but it was the
instability created by the Liz truss
mini budget that meant uh that our
mortgages went up even more so the
stability is really important it's not a
nice to have it's crucial but also you
need to be growing the economy and
supporting people at the very bottom as
well and that's something that labor
would do and I think the government
would do well to try and work with us on
some of those Solutions okay and they
test your green heart as well Grandpa
yes it's six years today that we had the
grenfell tower fire it was a few days
after I was elected to Parliament and uh
as 72 people lost their lives we are
still an absolute miles away from where
we need to be we still don't have
sprinklers even in the majority of our
social housing blocks let alone our
private blocks there are still thousands
and thousands of leaseholders who can't
sell their properties because we've got
fire safety issues that haven't been
resolved it's an opportunity to remember
those people who died but it's also a
call to action that the government need
to not forget that there is much more to
be done here okay thank you very much
thank you
labors Sarah Jones they're a bit of
breaking news to bring you now because
the Metropolitan Police have said that a
34 year old man has died on railroad
tracks in South London he was involved
in a car chase without officers and now
that's all the information that we have
at the minute but we will of course
bring you more details when we have them
a man there dying after a car chase with
metropolitan police officers
you're watching the take we're live in
Westminster for you this evening up next
we'll be hearing our question of the
week and this time it is focused on the
troubling rise of domestic abuse in
Northern Ireland even as the executive
there continues to be paralyzed by a
place called Deadlock
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back live to Westminster you're
watching the take now every week on the
show we like to pick our favorite
question from pmq something that
particularly caught our eye and this
week it was this one
prime minister 39 women have died
violently in Northern Ireland since
2017. the police are called to domestic
violence incident every 16 minutes and
hours is now one of the most dangerous
regions in Europe to be a woman
Stormwind has consulted on a strategy to
tackle violence against women but there
are no ministers to take it forward the
outstanding women's ahead Foundation
Federation learned last month that their
core funding is being taken away in the
demoralizing absence of a government
will the Prime Minister work with me and
others to ensure that strategy is
enacted and funded so that we can tackle
the cultures and behaviors that are
having such devastating impacts on women
in Northern Ireland
[Applause]
well that was the stlp's Claire Hannah
who joins us our live from Belfast
um thanks for being on the program uh
today can you just explain why you
decided to ask that question
yes thanks for having me on well I
suppose initially I was moved by the
murder of Chloe Mitchell age 21 who who
died in Northern Ireland was murdered
this week but unfortunately Chloe's
there
um is is far from isolated and as I
indicated
um in my question
um this is by far the highest uh Dev
tool for women in the most dangerous
place to be a woman and in fact the
femicide rates in Northern Ireland are
three times higher than they are in
England and Wales and we're on a par
only with Romania within Europe every
other month since 2020 a woman has died
at the hands of a partner or former
partner and unfortunately it's something
that isn't properly being tackled in the
absence of a government here I'll be
honest I'm really shocked by the
statistics that you're quoting it feels
pretty unbelievable actually why do you
think the situation is so bad I know
it's hard to give a reason but what's
going oh of course there is no one one
reason I mean um
across the world in post-conflict
societies I suppose there's a higher
tolerance maybe of that of violence and
complications
um around policing but um it's no
coincidence that we're also the only
place in Britain and Ireland that
doesn't have a dedicated strategy for
for tackling gender-based violence and
that is a coordinated action
um across public services and of course
this is a society-wide issue it starts
in schools and we're lagging far behind
on education around
um relationships and consent and respect
and right through to to modifications
that are needed in terms of family law
and better information sharing
um across uh organizations that deal
with people who are at risk but um just
uh in spite of that context we learned a
few weeks ago that the women's Aid
Federation who do a lot of um advocacy
and working with legislators and
fundraising for women's refuges in in
Northern Ireland and we're having their
core or Grant cut in Northern Ireland
due to two very
um difficult uh public finances but um
if we don't tackle this if we don't have
a coordinated strategy
um there's going to be more Chloe
Mitchells we're going to be
um more funerals and and more veg vigils
uh in the coming months so I use my
prime minister's question to try and
sign the alarm on the issue
well thank you for using your voice in
the way that you did I think there'll be
a lot of people who will be really
grateful to you for doing that
um you're talking about the lack of a
strategy and of course we know that
storm one is not up and running there's
no functioning government in Northern
Ireland how much of an impact is that
having
well so many problems unfortunately
um uh build up in Northern Ireland
because we have had this stop-start
governance over the last
um uh 10 and 20 years where um it's down
for a couple of years and it's up for a
couple of years and I suppose we're
always recovering from the last crisis
and we're really only uh legislating on
the absolutely uh urgent pieces of work
so you'll know it was done for three
years and came back just before the
pandemic and has been down for 15 months
and it just lets people down across
Health across education and in this case
um women and others experiencing
um gender-based violence and
um it is it is unfortunately the way
people uh here live they're let down by
the by the political system
um time and time again these aren't
unsolvable problems I mean domestic
violence of course is a surge across the
world but there are things that um that
governments can do but it needs to
become a priority in the way that
political parties make other things that
are Niche to them uh
a priority and and are not things that
affect
um women of all Community backgrounds
um at the beginning of the interview you
said that you've been partly driven to
ask your question about this because
what happened to a woman called Chloe
and sometimes I think that actually the
individual visual cases are what hit
home to people about what we're talking
about here so what did happen to Chloe
who who was Chloe well look um she was a
21 year old from from Ballymena in
County Antrim not somebody I I know but
um it's been deeply moving to listen to
her family her brother and her sister
talking about her
um over the last few days and her she
was just
um going dead on Monday so obviously we
don't know a lot of the cases of due to
say but as I say Chloe is not an
isolated statistic and every couple of
months
um uh Society here um hears of another
uh another story we were all very moved
by the murder of Natalie McNally over
the Christmas uh period uh uh a young
woman who was in the early stages of
pregnancy and who was killed by her
partner
um uh and I suppose it is just that fear
that there will be others and there are
other there are many women who may be
experiencing or fearing uh violence in
the home and it's about keeping
um hope for them and keeping crucially
and the services that they rely on as I
said police are are tackling uh just
under four uh call moles per hour on on
domestic violence and again policing
numbers are being cut
um as well so it's keeping all of these
issues live and ensuring that these like
core quality of life and protection of
Life issues
um Reach the the places on the political
uh our news agenda that they should do
Yeah you mentioned
um women in pregnancy and it's one of
the most shocking statistics I think
that so many cases of domestic abuse
start when someone is pregnant and thank
you so much for coming on the program
tonight and talking about such an
important issue thank you
thank you thank you
well let's return now to the cost of
living crisis that I spoke about with my
two political guests earlier in the
program and of course the very difficult
news for people needing to remortgage in
the coming months our economics and data
editor Ed Conway has a bit more on the
pain ahead
so we just got the latest data on the UK
economy the state of the economy GDP
here it is this is showing you the big
picture of gross domestic product the
size of the economy it's the level here
you can see the pandemic there that big
fall and the latest numbers show it's
0.2 growth uh in April but the thing I
want you to focus on is basically that
line we're kind of back at pre-pandemic
levels just about but essentially we're
flatlining and most economists think
it's going to carry on that way not
necessarily shrinking but if there is
even a slight deviation we could well be
in recession and the reason that matters
is we'll look at what's happening in the
mortgage market right now now these are
the average rates that people are paying
if you're reflexing your mortgage 5.54
this charcoals all the way back to the
1960s you can see there a bit higher for
two year break mortgages and it doesn't
look like it's very high does it that
line over there but higher since 2008
but here's the thing you've got to
adjust for the fact these are just the
headline mortgage rates just for the
fact that you have higher mortgages
right now people are more indebted they
have lower incomes in comparison with
their mortgages adjust for all of that
and it's a very different picture you
get a very different line an effective
rate really showing the burden that
people are facing going all the way back
to the 1960s and have a look where we
are right now is actually the highest
since 1991 and remember 1991 official
rates were up at 13 that precipitated a
housing crash a recession well we're
kind of getting up towards those levels
right now and we might get there we
might even exceed it why we'll have a
look at what's happened to interest rate
expectations so this is a future
interest rate expectations for the bank
of England they've gone up an awful lot
because inflation has been a lot higher
than expects a lot higher than the bank
expected by the way they've just
announced they're going to do an
external review of their inflation
forecasting uh in the face of criticism
this is what was expected only last
month so rates were gonna Peak around
4.75 in the next few years just look at
how that's changed now the expectation
is they're going up to 5.75 so closing
in on six percent by the end of the year
the tournament next year that is really
high and that's yet to feed through to
those mortgage charts I showed you a
moment ago so things could get really
tough for you particularly if you have a
mortgage
air Conway there pretty Grim have to say
uh my reaction to looking at some of
those graphs it was shown there you are
watching the take we're live in
Westminster for you this evening up next
we're going to be finding out what might
happen in Boris Johnson's old
constituency
[Music]
I'm Martha Kellner and I'm Sky's U.S
correspondent based here in Los Angeles
everybody into you know a crazy violent
drug addict
how are you feeling I am angry
it is an anti-woman agenda two women say
that you paid for their abortions are
you a hypocrite sir will your candidates
win I hope so but they will I think
they're great candidates
I got to be realistic my sister's dead
more than four weeks on there's no
murder weapon and no suspect are you
going to catch this killer we are doing
everything we can
Glenn Maxwell has pleaded not guilty to
all six charges against her man how are
you feeling today Jeffrey said you
answer to Gillian you just don't cross
her I'm so excited severe nightmares of
these people coming in and just taking
me in the middle of the night
I've watched as whole towns were torn
apart by natural disaster I'm alive and
I'm thankful for that but there are a
lot of people who aren't it's not the
winds people fear most here it's the
water
we take you to the heart of the stories
which shape our world do you truly
believe what you're saying
cases that I know are reported from
Ukrainian missiles themselves I'm busted
with respect I think that's preposterous
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take well we're
coming towards the end of the show but
today March the formal end for now at
least of the Parliamentary career of
Boris Johnson now Sam is with me again
and what this means is we've got three
by-elections to get stuck into if you're
anything like me and Sam then there's
nothing better than a by-election so
what have we got coming up then first
one of course Boris Johnson seat right
Oxbridge and South ruislip it's hard to
overstate just how big the stakes are
for all the parties in this three big
by-elections two of them like to take
place in either the 13th of July or the
21st of July we're still waiting to hear
which and this is in many ways the
biggest it is Boris Johnson's former
constituency in the west London seat of
Uxbridge now it's got a majority
currently in 2019 election of 7210 not
much which is not a lot and it would
cause about eight percent swing for
labor to win it they're gonna look to
try and overtake the position Boris
Johnson it is absolutely doable the
conservatives want to fight a campaign
on Sadiq Khan's charge for older diesel
vehicles known as the Euless they can
make it a you a referendum on the Euless
as they say they can they think they're
in with a little chart but this could be
a sensational result losing a former
Prime Minister's seat mid Parliament uh
and the next one we've got is this is
Nigel Adams old seat Celebi in agency I
have to say when I saw this I thought
oh looks kind of safe for the
conservatives the lib Dems you know
they're going to struggle to come from
that but actually people are saying that
it could be a bit tighter than that it's
fascinating all three by-elections could
be held or lost by the conservative
party nobody knows this one look it's a
Yorkshire sea it's a brexity seat and as
you say there's a huge twenty thousand
majority could there be a way back for
uh the labor party maybe we have been
experiencing Sensational shocks Nigel
Adams who stood down has been the MP
since 2010 at each election his majority
has increased so it looks hard this is
the one I think that the Tories will be
most hoping they can keep interesting
the one they most hoping they can keep
let's look at the third one at Mid
bedfordshire so this is Nadine Doris's
seat right and she hasn't even quit as
an MP formerly tonight she's saying
she's gonna wait a few more days to see
what she can find out about what
happened to her period that's probably
going to delay this by-election to
September meaning Morehead take for
issue that's something that's why she's
actually doing uh delaying her candidacy
now this one's really hard to read
because again it's actually the biggest
of the three majorities 24 000 but
actually labor and the liberal Democrats
both think that they're in with a shout
the lib Dems think that they did well in
seats like this at the local elections
but labor need to show that they're
doing well and they want to be
competitive here too is that a problem
though if they're both fighting yes and
it could mean that if they split the
vote then the Tories um come up through
the middle but I just wonder if it does
look like the lib Dems are in in pole
position in polling and uh can
canvassing and actually whether the
labor party just stepped back a little
bit and how much resource they put into
the sea and let the lib Dems take it but
that'll look bad particularly part of
the other two as well so interesting uh
three really fascinating by-elections to
come Sam thank you very much as always
for your analysis I'm Kate's uh there
with his take well we'll be back uh next
week and every week on Wednesday at 9 00
PM it's been another roller coaster week
in Westminster and of course we've got
the long-awaited Privileges committee
reports out tomorrow next up though it
is Sky News at 10. thanks very much for
watching this Wednesday evening
foreign
[Music]